Dance Moms has no shortage of drama or
at least that's what they want you to
think the reality TV show has its fair
share of bogus and authentic moments
keep watching to find out which popular
scenes were actually scripted and which
ones were 100% real I was shaking I was
appalled
it's no secret that Dance Moms is
scripted but just how much of it is real
Maddie Ziegler once told USA Today that
the producers of the show encouraged the
mothers to yell at each other because
well it makes the episodes that much
more entertaining
according to Maddie the moms have fake
fight sometimes and afterwards they just
start talking and laughing about it this
revelation was pretty upsetting for
Dance Moms fans everywhere especially
since the mothers spats were what kept
fans coming back for more
according to Radar Online competitive
dances are taped multiple times and the
producers go on to air the best takes
but while many moments are scripted the
show isn't a complete sham in fact there
are countless authentic moments that
simply couldn't be acted still there are
some inconsistencies like the fact that
many of the girls on Dance Moms are far
from being loyal
ALDC members like the show sets them out
to be the producers tweet clips to add
fuel to the fire and to make matters
worse they purposely tire out the cast
so that they get cranky which is a
surefire way to create dramatic fights
we've got some pretty surprising
scripted moments lined up for you and
some absolutely real ones too so don't
go anywhere let's kick things off with a
severely edited Dance Moms moment that
changed the tone of the entire episode
in season 2 episode 6 Maddie performed a
solo and slipped halfway through her
dance instead of running offstage as the
show claimed excuse me Maddie continued
dancing until she completed her number
but the producers chose to cut the rest
of her performance out and fast
forwarded it to when Maddie walked away
cradling her injury instead of focusing
on the fact that Maddie continued on
like a total champ they made it look
like her injury was worse than it really
was
okay and as if that wasn't bad enough
Abby Lee Miller chose to kick things up
a notch in season three in this episode
Kelly gets kicked out of the recital
after yelling at Abby for pulling
Paige's solo so but this heavily
influenced scene was far from being the
truth in reality Paige didn't want to do
her solo and Abby asked the girls would
anybody else like to do a new number
when no one did I be forced Maddie to
perform her solo but the producers made
it look like Maddie volunteered to take
Paige's solo away from her Kelly's
blowout had everything to do with a be
helping the producers strip the show and
nothing to do with Paige's solo while
we're on the subject of Paige we thought
we'd point out that many of her
on-screen moments were completely real
in season 3 episode 35 Paige suffered a
panic attack while rehearsing a dance
number
Abby was quick to say that Paige was
crying because she was being challenged
and didn't know her dance routine she
should know this dance just as well as
everybody else but in reality Paige was
a 12 year old who was under a whole lot
of stress the dancers panic attacks were
so real that Kelly had to bring her
daughter to therapy so that she could
learn to calm down her nerves
who could forget when Maddie and brynn
performed the together as one duet at
the fierce national dance competition
this moment occurred in season 6 episode
9 and fans were utterly horrified when
the music cut out during the girl's
performance
[Music]
Maddie and brynn kept going without fail
as Abby Lee whispered wise coaching's
from the audience well it turns out that
this moment was a total sham in truth
the music never actually cut out and
this was proven when the actual video
leaked online
showing the girls performing their dance
without any interruptions by now we all
know that Khloe left Dance Moms at the
end of season 4 because Abby Lee Miller
made fun of her medical condition since
it's never okay for an adult to make fun
of a child's appearance the producers of
the show tweaked the footage in Abby's
favor
in season 4 episode 32 we see Abby
tilling Christy we then see Christy
chasing Abby down the hall in reality
though the producers used a clip of a be
yelling at Cathy to cover up the fact
that Abby made fun of Chloe's eye and
worst of all as I Chloe heard when Abby
had said which is why the Lucas iax
chose to quit the show knocks it off one
of the craziest mom fights in the entire
series happened in season 3 episode 37
when the gang was in New Orleans Christi
and Leslie got into a physical
altercation after a day of drinking and
things got ugly real fast this fight was
completely real despite the producers
tweaking the footage we hear Christy say
before the moms get into a fight
but this sit-ins seemed to be planted it
doesn't sound natural and we don't
actually see Christy saying it the
producers probably didn't want to air
what actually was said and chose to
insert this clip as ammo regardless this
fight scene is totally legitimate during
an interview with OK Magazine
Kalani Hilliker revealed that the season
5 finale was heavily staged
Cavani and Nia were made to compete
against each other in hopes of winning
the chance to perform a solo routine at
nationals
Nia ended up winning the competition but
the viewers weren't given the entire
story turns out that Kalani did in fact
perform a solo at nationals
it just wasn't aired on the show Nia and
Kalani were made to face off in an
intense dance battle because it was
entertaining and nothing more
Louis going head-to-head to see who's
gonna perform at nationals
in truth many of the girls go on to
perform solos when the cameras aren't
watching they simply make it look like
there's only one solo available to hype
up the drama so well you guys surprised
to find out that these moments were
scripted or heavily tweeks by the show's
producers let us know in the comment
section give this video a big thumbs up
if you love Dance Moms and don't forget
to hit that subscribe button for more
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows thanks for watching see you next
time on the things
[Music]